you  I like to move it move it he likes to  move it move it she likes to move it  move it we like to you ever come to look  at stuff in Manhattan feel free to call  first surprised I'm lady which of you  was attracted to me  seriously though Paul buckle up boys  don't look dawg this might get hairy  we've lost engine 1 an engine clue is no  longer on fire attention this is your  captain speaking  I've got good news and bad news the good  news is we'll be landing immediately  bad news is crash landing thanks again  for choosing here think it's more fun  with your hands like this  I love you Gloria I always have boy good  landing boys who says a penguin can't  fly  you